[Musica]
dunque senza tanti giri di parole direi
che puntiamo dritti all'obiettivo perché
oggi assieme a voi vorrei sfatare un
mito un mito che c'è nello spot in tutto
lo sport quello olimpico così come in
quello delle parrocchie in quello che si
usa che si giocano i tornei di quartiere
e vorrei assieme a voi sfatare il mito
che riguarda il binomio sconfitta e
vittoria vittoria sconfitta per cui la
vittoria dà ragione e la sconfitta da
torto perché quando si perde si ha
commesso si sono commessi degli errori
vero
e quando si vince non si è sbagliato una
virgola giusto
ecco io questo mito vorrei sfatare
insieme a voi
e vorrei farlo partendo dal racconto di
alcuni episodi che riguardano la mia
storia
adesso magari tanti di voi sono talmente
giovani che non ricordano neanche delle
mie ultime imprese di più grandi magari
conoscono sulla parte italiana ma vorrei
assieme a voi tornare al passato a quei
tempi in cui io disputavo la prima e la
seconda olimpiade allora venite con me
nel 1984 siamo a los angeles e io per
partecipare a quel olimpiade avevo fatto
una serie di rinunce importanti avevo
smesso con la scuola a stavo facendo
lavoro part time per poter seguire tutte
le indicazioni del mio natore che aveva
una programmazione molto molto accurata
una tabella di marcia molto importante
e allora figuratevi arriviamo a un
bacino di los angeles e mio povero
allenatore viene a sapere che non
possiamo allenarci di pomeriggio perché
tirava sempre vento dal deserto invece
noi ragazze 0 preoccupazione perché
credevamo si nel lavoro ma abbiamo fatto
di necessità virtù e abbia siamo goduti
il clima olimpico è così il giorno della
finale assieme alla mia cardin d'occhio
ci avviamo verso la partenza e siamo
come un tutt'uno anche se in passato non
poche volte avevamo litigato perché io
non coglievo mai il suo cose fosse bravo
veramente una cosa impossibile però quel
giorno siamo un tutt'uno una sinfonia ci
alleniamo allineiamo e partiamo ci
distendiamo combattiamo ecco vi direi
che abbiamo fatto così ma in realtà non
ricordo quella gara non ricordo nulla di
quella gara
ricordo solo che poi a un certo punto
abbiamo tagliato il traguardo siamo
arrivate per se qualcuno potrebbe dire
dai un fronzolo impieri su roba da
bambini
però per noi era una cosa davvero
importante perché fino a quel giorno lì
non solo andavano ha mai messo piede su
un podio olimpico ma va mai messo piede
su un podio di un mondiale e non avevo
mai messo piede su un podio di una gara
internazionale perché poi vincevano
sempre la rete l'est vite sapere che non
poche volte mi capitava a tornare lunedì
mattina dopo un contesto internazionale
che mi beccavo mentre fischiavo
l'inno russo opere della germania
dell'est e perché non c'era scampo
vincevano sempre loro o in
quell'edizione via los angeles bancario
rados angeles mancavano gli abeti nei
paesi comunisti perché loro avevano
boicottato in risposta si dice per
ripicca al boicottaggio di mosca dove
l'ovest aveva dato forfait per
stigmatizzare l'invasione russa in
afghanistan e meno avendo lei se non ci
sono e non glielo abbiamo impedito
quindi eravamo contenti etico e il
risultato o poi dopo qualche giorno mi è
successa una cosa un po un po strana
perché dice oh beh abbiamo battuto le
rumene le uniche dell'es presenti ma le
avversarie più forti
mancavano quindi a quella vera felicità
per il traguardo raggiunto si si è
aggiunto un retrogusto un po
agrodolci perché
mancavano la rete più forte in quel
momento nessuna promessa che l'avrei
messa tutta per vincere una medaglia di
diane vera per linkedin su quattro anni
dopo e così ho fatto per i successivi
quattro anni
esistevano solo due cose allenamenti e
formazione professionale seguendo quello
che è stato l'indicazione del mio
allenatore che credeva nell'abitazione e
nell'impegno a tutto campo non vede
ruote io correvo dalla mattina alla sera
si ore di lezione la mattina quattro ore
di allenamento il pomeriggio e correvo
su e giù tra il centro federale a scuola
di polizia
non vi dico quante volte mi sono
addormentata addirittura mentre tornavo
la si era cotta come un cc come si usa
dire da nuovo in romagna è però mi
sembrava un prezzo congruo un pezzo
grongo rovescia verso la vittoria
e infatti i conti tornavano dal lamento
e il mio allenatore mi avrebbero già
potuto se gara l'una di notte e senza
togliere il pigiama avrei fatto quell 1
57 che si arriva che vince la medaglia
peccato che poi in gara in gara si
fermasse sempre sempre sempre su 202 era
come una maledizione dopo un po detto ma
come disperavo ero giù di morale dice ma
come pure la sto mettendo tutta e tempi
tornano
voglio con tutta la mia forza arrivare a
questo risultato mi confidavo col mio
con dio diario scrivevo coro coruna più
coro più ma lontano sapessi da cosa
sarei già a metà strada è vero in tilt e
c'era qualcosa che mi sfuggiva ma ero
troppo impigliata per comprendere cosa
fosse poi qualcosa che mi sta sfuggendo
così ad un certo punto arrivò alle
olimpiadi non poteva andare bene
diventare bene e ho perso e vi ricordate
quel mito che volevamo set sfatare per
cui la vittoria porta ragione e la
sconfitta dava torto e allora però io
avevo bene fa tanto bene tutto il mio
amato re ha detto diane usando siamo
andati bene ci ha dato ragione abbiamo
rincarato la dose però poi cosa è
successo in quei quattro anni noi non lo
sappiamo
fatto sta che perdevo cardillo e questa
sconfitta mi dava torto ma mi dava
veramente torto perché come aveva detto
la prestazione c'era ma non veniva fuori
in gara
forse
era una persona di atteggiamento beh su
questo devo dire che se la sono cavata
con pochi perché tempo di tagliare il
traguardo per ultima è la sentenza era
pronta la leader non ha forza mentale
ormai troppo vecchia per vincere
fate conto avevo 24 anni 24 anni ero
troppo vecchia per vincere
fa ridere un po i poli è però ormai a
robot lata come una colpevolmente debole
di mente pure l'aveva messa tutta e dopo
lunghe di risi 1 cambiato vita sono
dovuto in italia e ho iniziato a
prepararmi a sì ma mio marito e insieme
anno dopo anno ci siamo messi a lavorare
sul mio dono il talento di fas corna
barca e anno dopo anno è cresciuto il
nostro pecori colom e in curriculum ci
sono tutte quelle medaglie che
sono stati ci sono state citate prima e
devo dire che quel curriculum sarebbe
stato ancora più ricco questo è vero se
ci fosse da stata quella medaglia siul
che era alla mia portata
però oggi a distanza
mi son convinta che c'era molto più ha
ragione al che porto in quelle sconfitte
perché se avessi vinto avrei dovuto dare
ragione al mio all'attore che predicava
la sapienza krifi cio la fatica fine a
se stessa e forse perdeva anche per non
dare ragione a me cari tenevo quel mio
malessere indefinibile un prezzo congruo
da pagare avete capito che mi ero
dimenticata di vivere e senza esserne
consapevole ritenevo questo un pezzo non
compro un prezzo troppo alto da pagare a
torto chiama nel 90 primo mondiale per
l'italia
vinco torniamo a casa ci fermiamo a
potsdam in germania est e infiliamo tra
il trionfo è il nostro matrimonio che
avremmo dovuto festeggiare qui che dopo
ci fermiamo in questa vasca fuga della
germania est bobba top secret fino
all'anno prima quindi mio marito non ha
resistito mi ha fatto fare quelle teste
a tre giorni dal mondiale tanto impedire
che ha deviato tedesco in casa nostra
perché ci fermiamo con il bio meccanico
dopo i test
e io guardo i dati e lo guardo incredula
e dico ma cos'è sta roba è la mia
tecnica
sì ma fa schifo ma se appena vinto i
mondiali e lui lei al 20 mondiali tre
giorni fa e adesso sa dove può
migliorare e l'ambiente anche capito che
avrei festeggiato piuttosto la vittoria
e avrei piuttosto preparato quel
matrimonio però col senno di poi devo
dire che è stata geniale l'idea di mio
marito fermarci lì e mettermi di fronte
ai miei difetti tre giorni dopo i
mondiali
e lui è veramente una persona che sa non
una ma due marce in più e io a loro in
corso negli anni e per fortuna alla fine
il somatica arrivata pietro ma quelli
veri e stata veramente ge tale che
quindi io avevo vinto nonostante la mia
tecnica quando si vince si ha ragione
non si sbagliano una virgola no ma io
avevo vinto nonostante per la tecnica
scadente poi andiamo a sydney 2000
arrivò al campo alle 8 di mattina e sono
spaventatissima quando vedo volar via
tende imbarcazione da quanto è forte il
vento ma siamo all'ultimo giorno delle
tv a sera avrebbero spinto la fiamma
olimpica si che la gara era da fare in
quella giornata mentre
ci rincorriamo in rinvio dopo l'altro mi
scatta alla fame e tecnici decidono di
tornare in albergo per prenderci da
mangiare non potete crederci con cosa
son tornati sono tornati con i
tortellini un tortellini e cosa faceva
ho mangiato e poi avevano detto che tra
l'annuncio e la gara effettiva sarebbe
passata un'ora
le ultime parole famose finito di
mangiare via in partenza e devo dire che
quel mondiale l'ho vinto nonostante
fossi stata posseduta durante tutto il
percorso dal pensiero che andava a quel
pasto sbagliato che avevo fatto prima
della gara
allora la vera cosa buffa arriva perché
dopo londra un nostro amico dopo la gara
mi fa mai mangiato i tortellini prima
della finale io la dico ma sei matto ma
ti pare
lui no perché guarda e che tu dici
sempre di aver vinto nonostante i
tortellini via assieme ma poi dopo non
li hai mai più mangiati dopo la finale
ma non hai nemmeno più vinto quindi
forse non è che hai vinto nonostante
quelli lì ma forse hai vinto grazie ai
tortellini
direi che non fa una piega
direi che questo ragionamento non fa una
piega
e allora per arrivare alla conclusione
avrei vorrei condividere 3 item che in
estrema sintesi riassumano un po ciò che
ci siamo detti fino adesso primo item da
quando mi fanno ascoltare le storie dei
campioni e vi dicono che dovete fare
come loro
fatevi venire il dubbio che forse loro
hanno vinto grazie a tutto ciò che hanno
fatto bene ma anche nonostante tutto ciò
che hanno combinato fino a quel punto 2
quando mi dicono che la sconfitta è
un'ottima opportunità che a sgamare i
propri errori è contemplata anche la
possibilità che il 3 abbia sbagliato la
programmazione e oltre aver sbagliato
l'abito saggio dell'impegno forse vi
state semplicemente trovando nel fim
sbagliato
e allora vanno ancora molto di moda quel
paradigma militar dell'obbedienza o
quello religioso per cui se solo sulla
vita terrena compiamo tanti sacrifici
andremo andremo dritto in paradiso ma
quando siamo sbagliati quella storia del
cult e sacrificio non funziona e allora
arriviamo a dritti al 3 dal piazza
height volere è potere e ciò che ci
inculcano da quando siamo bambini però
non è sempre così perché poi ci sono dei
limiti veri e per cui non basta può non
bastare
un ottimismo ha capito per vedere
realizzati i propri sogni
e allora per arrivare a in via limiti
mia immaginiamoci la gara a cui
partecipano 10 mila persone e non è che
per quella cifra poi posti sul podio
aumentano e allora comune mamme che la
mettiamo con quei 9mila 997 che non
vanno sul podio sono da con serate dei
falliti perché non avevano abbastanza
forza di volontà sono degli asini poi
guardate che i timidi limiti non sono
solo
la nostra testa ci sono dei limiti veri
allora può succedere che uno partecipi e
quando perde non è che diventa
automaticamente un idiota e se la
mettiamo così la sconfitta acquisisce
tutto un altro sapore
allora dopo ci sta a partecipare e ci
sta vincere o perdere nessuno per la sua
dignità che guardate che la vittoria è
l'eccezione e non la regola
adesso vedo che qualcuno magari pensa la
guarda cosa ci racconta non facile per
le ads ha vinto tutto e poi ci parla del
valore della sconfitta
allora giornata un attimo con me a quel
periodo lì di los angeles
seul è doverosa una premessa se uno
vuole raggiungere un risultato non può
prescindere dall'impegno dalla prassi
garanza dalla costanza dalla voglia di
farcela però è fatto è che c'è modo e
modo per arrivarci perché poi dopo tutte
queste storie qua a qualcuno mi ha detto
ma dopo ai anche vinte grazie al fatto
che ha imparato a resistere a tutte
quelle intemperie
ci ho messo un po di anni per ricordarmi
che no no io ero così da bambina io da
bambina ero cocciuta che star da curiosa
creativa e resistente guardate che a tre
anni mi sono spaccata la fronte perché a
tutti i costi la dovevo scendere da me
la dà il triciclo in cantina poi mia zia
mi ha funzione mi ha chiuso in cantina
perché non ne poteva più di tutte le
domande che le potevo vedere che le
ponevo sul mondo e mi sono insegnata da
sola a nuotare perché mi faceva
impazzire mio papà che che non portava a
pazienza quindi io i requisiti d amico
eppure ormai smith dopo perché ormai mia
vivono quasi rubato quel dono che
portavo in linea di partenza
e negli andamenti e se allora questa
storia mi è capitata da ventenne questa
storia della obbedienza del sacrificio
chi ha a che fare un po con i bambini
oggi e chi vede come siccome allineano
ai bambini piccoli sa che oggi questa
storia del sacrificio e del sudore
scatta già per i bambini piccoli non si
può prescindere a questo però perché poi
da adulto si vive bene e serenamente la
gara con un momento per esprimersi nella
bellezza delle proprie competenze
occorre partire bene è partire bene
significa permettere ai bambini
esprimere pieno flusso delle loro
possibilità ed è per questo che oggi io
mi impegno moltissimo a diffondere nuovo
paradigma dentro allo sport giovanile
quindi fatemi terminare con un appello a
tutti quelli che lavorano con i bambini
affinché per i bambini ci sia allegria
gioia e creatività e gioco e affinché
per loro possa esserci in futuro una
bella storia da raccontare
attorno allo sport vi ringrazio